the embattled ride-hailing giant uber
potentially faces more legal trouble
this morning Uber's in the new CEO
reportedly knew about the hack of writer
and driver data for more than two months
before revealing it publicly this week
information from about 57 million riders
and six hundred thousand drivers was
exposed in October 2016
uber paid the hackers 100 thousand
dollars to delete the stolen data but
it's unclear if they did we reached out
to her for a statement but have yet to
hear back CBS News financial contributor
Mellody Hobson is in San Francisco with
more on this story melody good morning
to you hope you had a nice Thanksgiving
good morning
so how big of a setback is this for
Oberer well you know that's saying it's
not the crime it's the cover-up I would
call this a setback another in a series
of setbacks that they have had another
reputational hit and it's one that
they're going to have to continue to dig
themselves out of this hole and it's
going to take a while you know melody
ubers new CEO reportedly waited two
months before revealing it to the public
there have been issues with Travis
kalanick I mean what does this say about
the credibility this early in his tenure
well I have to say on this one I'm gonna
take him at his word that he needed to
investigate he said that he learned two
weeks after he joined or it's been
reported that he learned two weeks after
he joined of this breach and he needed
to take the time to figure out exactly
what it was the issue is however they
have an investor coming in Softbank that
they had lured it to the breach two
weeks before they alerted the public so
they'll have to square that circle for
people to have them understand how the
investor got to know at least that they
were having an investigation not the the
outcome of the investigation two weeks
earlier melody uber has 57 million
customer profiles affected in this hack
they're telling customers they don't
need to be concerned the information
hasn't been used in any way that will
affect them but really give us a reality
check here should people be worried I
think this is a world now where you have
to assume that you have to be worried
about your personal information
everywhere assume that you've been
breached that's the best way to work and
to move forward from this point now in
this situations it was names email
addresses and phone numbers for most
people
driver's license numbers for some of the
drivers 600,000 drivers but I would say
that you want to make sure that you are
vigilant about looking at your credit
report the free one that you can get
annually that you're actually reading
your bank and your credit card
statements that you're protecting your
passwords these things are now going to
just be table stakes for showing up in
this world today because of the amount
of data that is moving around in Melodi
this applies not only to Oberer but to
everybody who's going shopping online
this weekend and who has all of their
data in many cases on their phones
correct that's right so you want to make
sure just avoid public Wi-Fi secure
sites you know again protect those
passwords
alright Mellody Hobson in San Francisco
forest melody thank you very much